do you ever anticipate a problem like
with guys that are supposed to be
fighting each other you know like what
just happened with Maz Badal recently
like we're an actual fist fight breaks
out and you find most of these guys want
to get paid to fight not pay to fight
right but when you see like cameras
aren't on they're not so that fight yeah
that's true right when the cameras
aren't on the other thing is when you're
leading into a fight my thought was you
cannot let that person think they
intimidated you and if that means you
actually have to hit them maybe it does
but you know the idea is that I can't
let you think that you have a mental
advantage right in any other sport so we
know I ever want to see that like like
yeah stop that but in fighting it's like
oh they're just doing extra fighting
yeah yeah like if it's a basketball
player sucker punch is another
basketball player in the face it's some
sort of a press conference like that
like Maz Badal did I mean you'd be like
what yeah no way but in fighting like
Ali did extra fighting do people for
that performance was going to get extra
money stunning knockout of Darren tills
one of the top guys in the welterweight
division the way Kaden was crazy so he
got it from that and then to tee off on
Leon Edwards after the fight like that
it's like another one like that's part
of that it's very good for him
unfortunately like I don't want him to
do that I don't wanna encourage but if
you want to think about like a fighters
popularity building in there Bradley
he's an I don't give a fuck I'll punch
you in the face guy and like well a lot
of people are know he's a real and I
don't give a fuck I'll punch you in your
face guy they're real they're really
exist and he's a world-class fighter
like that's a that's sellable it's
unfortunate I wish guys wouldn't ever
fight at press conferences like Cormier
and John Jones I fucking hated that but
tell me that didn't sell more tickets
so don't that's sold a shitload more
tickets how many times they throat show
concentrate on that Dali oh how many
times they show that even in the promos
I hated when that happened it was a
terrible thing that Connor did that got
damn that's awesome and that's a that's
a fine line right
oh yeah people that weren't even
involved got cut yeah got hit with no
ass I don't I can't mean that I mean
using it promoted yes yes yes we just
tried to void it and hide it or do we
let people know that this is a real
thing
call all people involved go looked is
the business we're here to get paid okay
we're gonna run it we're gonna run it
every 15 minutes we're gonna show that
dolly smash oh and that's will Harris's
company is that the the gentleman what
is it what is it called not to me of a
fighter yes that's his youtube show that
I often thought was a UFC show I didn't
even know that he had his own show